cybersecurity has become a struggle for
organizations in 2021.
recent trends the side effects of a
global pandemic and cyber security
statistics reveal a huge increase in
hacked and breached data for
increasingly common sources in the
workplace like mobiles and iot devices
on top of this the covert 19 has ramped
up remote workforces making inroads for
cyber attacks
this kind of growth would not have been
possible if not for several reliable
tools and services
from scripts that find intricate details
of companies to software that can brute
force servers with a single command
today's lesson is all about such tools
that make an ethical hacker effective
hey everyone this is bever from simply
learn and welcome to this video on the
top 5 ethical hacking tools let's take a
look at the topics we need to cover
today
we start by learning the basics of
ethical hacking and how it differs from
the general public idea of cyber
criminals
we learn about the various types of
ethical hacking and the respective
personnel that carry out these attacks
moving on we reach our main focus for
the lesson which are the top five
ethical hacking tools that every
cybersecurity analyst must master
and finally we learn about a few
benefits of ethical hacking and how it
can be used to the advantage of
organizations
let's learn about what is ethical
hacking in our first section
ethical hacking involves an authorized
attempt to gain unauthorized access to a
computer system application or data
carrying out an ethical hack involves
duplicating strategies and actions of
malicious attackers
often carried out in the form of
security audits ethical hacking is
extremely beneficial to organizations
who are looking to secure the data from
falling in the wrong hands
there are three variants of hackers
while a black hat hacker is notorious
for criminal activities
white hat is an ethical hacker or a
computer security expert who specializes
in penetration testing and other testing
methodologies that ensure the security
of an organization system
there are a few that fall under the gray
hat hacker umbrella where the hacker
occasionally have not authenticated
themselves before attempting to hack an
organization while sometimes requiring a
small fee to report the vulnerability to
the developers directly
the purpose of ethical hacking is to
improve the security of the network or
the systems by fixing the
vulnerabilities found during testing
ethical hackers may use the same methods
and tools used by the malicious hackers
but with the permission of the
authorized person for the purpose of
improving the security and defending the
systems from attacks
ethical hackers are expected to report
all the vulnerabilities and weaknesses
found during the process to the
management directly
ethical hacking has proven itself to be
quite a productive career option for
many ambitious individuals the demand
for its courses today is at an all-time
high and rightfully so it provides you
with an engaging job that never gets
tedious some certifications like the
comptia plus ceh and cisco ccna are
highly acclaimed and will teach a
learner all there is to know before
dipping their toes in the industry
when it comes to web app hacking it
generally refers to the exploitation of
applications by http which can be done
by manipulating the applications via its
graphical user interface this is done by
tampering with the uniform resource
identifier also known as a uri or
tampering with the http elements
directly which are not a part of the uri
the hacker can send a link via an email
or a chat and may trick the users of a
web application into executing actions
in case the attack is on an
administrator account the entire web
application can be compromised
anyone who uses a computer connected to
the internet is susceptible to the
threats that computer hackers and online
predators pose these online villians
typically use phishing scams spam email
or instant messages and bogus websites
to deliver dangerous malware to your
computer and compromise their computer
security
computer hackers can also try to access
your computer and private information
directly if you are not protected by a
firewall they can monitor your
conversations or peruse the back end of
your personal website
usually disguised with a bogus identity
predators can lure you into revealing
sensitive personal and financial
information
a web server which can be referred to as
the hardware the computer or the
software which helps to deliver content
that can be accessed through the
internet the primary function of a web
server is to deliver these web pages on
the request to clients using the
hypertext transfer protocol or http
so hackers attack the web server to
steal credential information passwords
and business information by using
different types of attacks like ddos
attacks syn flooding ping flood port
scan and social engineering attacks
in the area of web security despite
strong encryption on the browser server
channel web users still have no
assurance about what happens at the
other end
although wireless networks offer great
flexibility they have their own security
problems a hacker can sniff the network
packets without having to be in the same
building where the network is located as
wireless networks communicate through
radio waves a hacker can easily sniff
the network from a nearby location
most attackers use network sniffing to
find the ssid and hack a wireless
network
an attacker can attack a network from a
distance and therefore it is sometimes
difficult to collect evidence against
the main hacker
social engineering is the art of
manipulating uses of a computing system
into revealing confidential information
which can be later used to gain
unauthorized access to a computer system
the term can also include activities
such as exploiting human kindness greed
and curiosity to gain access to
restricted access buildings or getting
the users to installing backdoor
software
knowing the tricks used by hackers to
trick users into releasing vital login
information is fundamental in protecting
computer systems
coming to our main focus for today let
us have a look at the top 5 most
essential ethical hacking tools to be
used in 2021
at the top of the chain lies nmap
nmap which stands for network mapper is
a free and open source utility for
network discovery and security auditing
many systems and network administrators
also find it useful for tasks such as
network inventory managing service
upgrade schedules and monitoring host or
service uptime
it is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking where a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system before running the necessary
exploits thus allowing the hackers to
leverage any insecure openings and thus
breach the device
nmap users draw ib packets in novel ways
to determine what hosts are available on
the network what service they are
running what operating systems are
installed what type of packet filters
and firewalls are in use and dozens of
other characteristics it was designed to
rapidly scan large networks but works
fines against single host as well
since every application that connects to
a network needs to do so via a port
the wrong port or a server configuration
can open a can of worms which lead to a
thorough breach of the system and
ultimately a fully hacked device
next on our list we have metasploit the
metasploit framework is a very powerful
tool that can be used by cyber criminals
as well as ethical hackers to probe
systematic vulnerabilities on both
networks and servers
because it's an open source framework it
can be easily customized and used with
most operating systems
with metasploit the ethical hacking team
can use ready-made or custom code and
introduce it into a network to probe for
weak spots
as another flavor of threat hunting once
the flaws are identified and documented
the information can be used to address
systemic weaknesses and prioritize
solutions
once a particular vulnerability is
identified and the necessary exploit is
fed into the system there are a host of
options for the hacker depending on the
vulnerability hackers can even run root
commands from the terminal allowing
complete control over the activities of
the compromise system as well as all the
personal data stored on the device
a big advantage of metasploit is the
ability to run full-fledged scans on the
target system which gives a detailed
picture of the security index of the
system along with the necessary exploits
that can be used to bypass the antivirus
software
having a single solution to gather
almost all the necessary points of
attack is very useful for ethical
hackers and penetration testers as
denoted by its high rank in the list
moving on we have the acunetix framework
ackinetix is an end-to-end web security
scanner which offers a 360 degree view
of an organization's security
it is an application security testing
tool that helps the company address
vulnerability across all their critical
web assets
the need to be able to test application
in depth and further than traditional
vulnerability management tools has
created a market with several players in
the application security space
acunetix can detect over 7000
vulnerabilities including sql injections
cross-site scripting misconfigurations
weak passwords xposed database and other
out-of-band vulnerabilities
it can scan all pages web apps and
complex web applications running html5
and javascript as well it also lets you
scan complex multi-level forms and even
password-protected areas of the site
iqnetics is a dynamic application
security testing package which has
definite births over status application
security testing frameworks which are
also known as sasd scanners
sast tools only work during development
and only for specific languages and have
a history of reporting lot of false
positives whereas dynamic testing tools
also known as dst have the ability to
streamline testing from development to
deployment with minimal issues
next on our list we have airgarden
this is a multi-use bash script used for
linux systems to hack and audit wireless
networks like our everyday wifi router
and its counterparts
along with being able to launch denial
of service attacks on compromised
networks this multi-purpose wi-fi
hacking tool has very rich features
which support multiple methods for wi-fi
hacking including wps hacking modes wp
attacks handshake captures evil twin and
so much more
it usually needs an external network
adapter that supports monitor mode which
is necessary to be able to capture
wireless traffic that traverse the air
channels
thanks to its open source nature
air garden can be used with multiple
community plug-ins and add-ons thereby
increasing its effectiveness against a
wide variety of routers both in the 2.4
gigahertz and the 5 gigahertz band
finally at number 5 we have john the
ripper
john the ripper is an open source
password security auditing and the
password recovery tool which is
available for many operating systems
john the ripper jumbo supports hundreds
of hash and cipher types including for
user passwords of operating systems web
apps database servers encrypted keys and
document files
some of the key features of the tool
include offering multiple modes to speed
up the password cracking automatically
deselecting the hashing algorithm used
by the passwords and the ease of running
and configurating the tool to make it
password cracking easier
it can use dictionary attacks along with
regular brute forcing to speed up the
process of cracking the correct password
without wasting additional resources
the word list being used in these
dictionary attacks can be used by the
users and allowing for a completely
customizable process
we also have a few honorary mentions in
our list that just missed the card
netsparker for instance is an automated
yet fully configurable web application
security scanner that enables you to
scan websites web applications and web
services the scanning technology is
designed to help you secure web
applications easily without any fuss so
you can focus on fixing the reported
vulnerabilities
the burp suit professional is one of the
most popular penetration testing and
vulnerability finder tools and is used
for checking web application security
the term burp as it is commonly known is
a proxy based tool which is used to
evaluate the security of web-based
application and to do hands-on testing
moving away from websites and
applications wireshark is a free and
open source packet analyzer which was
launched in 2006.
it is used for network troubleshooting
analysis software and communications
protocol development and education
it captures network traffic on the local
network and stores data for offline
analysis
wireshark captures network traffic from
ethernet bluetooth wireless networks and
frame relay connections
now that we learn about the different
types of tools that can be used when
conducting an ethical hacking audit
let's learn about some potential
benefits of such campaigns and why
organizations prefer to pay for such
audits
being able to identify defects from an
attacker's perspective is game changing
since it displays all the potential
avenues of a possible hack one can only
prepare for the known vulnerabilities as
a defensive specialist but proactively
trying to breach a network or device can
make hackers think of techniques that no
defense contractors can account for
this kind of unpredictability goes a
long way in securing a network against
malicious actors
another advantage of hiring ethical
hackers is the ability to preemptively
fix possible weak points in a company's
network infrastructure
as seen on many occasions a real breach
will cause loss of data and irreparable
damage to the foundation of an
organization
being able to gauge such shortcomings
before they become public and can be
used exploited is a benefit most
organizations make use of
this is not to imply that such security
audits are only beneficial to the
organization paying for it when coming
across companies that provide certain
services a reliable third party security
audit goes a long way in instilling
trust and confidence over the craft if
the ethical hackers cannot find any
major vulnerabilities that can be
leveraged by hackers it just accentuates
the technical brilliance of the
organization and its engineers thereby
increasing the clientele by a
substantial amount
hope you learned something interesting
today if you have any doubts regarding
the topics mentioned in the lesson
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and we will get
back to you as soon as possible thank
you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here